it's language used to describe among
others my next two guests both
instrumental in gaining concessions from
newly minted speaker Kevin McCarthy
joining us now Florida Congressman Matt
Gates Colorado congresswoman Lauren
bobert great to see both of you
Congressman Gates
how confident are you that the
concessions that you guys ended up
winning
are enforceable and you can hold on to
them for these next two years just
moments ago we passed the rules for the
118th Congress and those included the
enforcement mechanism of the one member
motion to vacate now I don't anticipate
that we'll ever have to use that but it
gives us the opportunity to ensure that
our goals regarding policy procedure and
Personnel are met we're going to have
votes on term limits balanced budgets
internal enforcement of our immigration
laws none of those things would have
happened if we had caved on Monday but
by getting these concessions and coming
to a stronger place the house is in a
stronger position now here's how the
Democrats are responding to the rules
package just past moments ago
these rules are not a serious attempt at
governing they're essentially a ransom
note to America from the extreme right
you're still empowering the extremists
don't take my word for let's go through
their rules package they're giving a
single member the ability to remove the
speaker at any time letting a small
far-right faction hold their leadership
hostage
congresswoman you know your fault
apparently that's usually what the
Democrats like to say but this empowers
every individual member of Congress even
the Democrats that single member motion
to vacate is for them as well these
single subject legislation uh pieces
that we're going to see this is
something that we have in 47 state
legislatures to have it on a federal
level is massive so I'm proud that we
took a few extra days to make sure that
we get this right it may look like chaos
and dysfunction but I'm a mom of four
boys that's a part of my everyday life
and really last week was the most
productive week I have experienced in
Congress people really saw behind the
curtain of what happens in Washington
stuff that you know I've been reeling
against for 20 plus years 25 years these
Omnibus spending bills nobody knows
what's in them it's just junk in the
kitchen sink thrown in things that
congressmen and Senators don't want to
be held accountable for so you can't say
you voted against border enforcement
what they say Congressman Gates is oh no
I just voted to keep the government open
that's essentially what they do correct
well and the whole sum of this movement
was to ensure that never again would be
we'd be forced to take a vote on
something like this Omnibus legislation
and I actually think this will make
Kevin McCarthy stronger as a speaker
because in negotiating with the Senate
he'll be able to say I'm sorry the house
rules don't allow us to consider things
that aren't germane or that don't
comport to a single subject yeah make it
better now the issue of defense spending
I brought this up several times last
week that's always treated as the sacred
cow can never touch defense spending no
matter how woke the Pentagon is no
matter how much scrutiny the Pentagon
needs for its failures we all support
our men and women in uniform but the
idea that 55 percent of our
discretionary budget can't be touched
those numbers don't add up with the cuts
that you all want correct unless you
guys ultimately start thinking about
cutting parts of the military we're
certainly going to have to look at a
number of things to get this budget
you can't get away with it
many things that we're going to to look
at but defense is that's the biggest
number it is that is absolutely one of
them and we have a lot of Defense Hawks
in the House of Representatives that are
probably going to put up a fight for
that but we have to have a budget that
actually balances and that's what this
Congressman Gates on that forward that's
the defense issue the Hawks in the
Republican party and some of the
Democrat parties saying no no no no no
you can't touch that I heard the
comments even tonight you can't touch
the defense you're being irresponsible
with National Security The Wall Street
Journal at a very powerful piece today
National Security is at risk with what
you guys did I represent the district
that has the highest concentration of
active duty military in the country and
we can defend this country and project
power more efficiently and more
effectively than we do president Trump
was the first president to demand an
audit of the Pentagon and they couldn't
pass defense well we got an audit so we
show where they fail to actually deliver
on some of the authorities and how about
we start with Ukraine before we reduce
before we reduce what we do for our
troops I think it's pretty it's a pretty
easy case to make the that some of this
money that we send to Ukraine without
requisite accountability should be the
first place for reduction all right we
got to play this video this was the real
dramatic video on Friday night so we
were live 10 to 11 and all this stuff
was happening in the hour and minutes
after we got off the air this is one of
the most talked about moments McCarthy
comes over toward you uh you see it gets
heated Lauren is that you right next to
us yeah there's there are you now Fox
News reported that you appeared to mild
the word committee during this exchange
I guess you had a lip reader Congressman
the world wants to know what was said
here come on this is a pivotal moment
what was said well this was a matter of
timing and those of us who had withheld
our support for speaker McCarthy wanted
to move as a group we thought it could
be a unifying moment I'm glad that to
speaker McCarthy's great credit in the
final moments he made the requisite
concessions to bring our team together
and put us in a great position to do
what we did tonight vote to get rid of
87 000 IRS agents so I think that you
know the Imperial speakership is over
Nancy Pelosi will be the last Imperial
speaker because now we're going to
unlock the potential in all the members
and I'm glad that speaker McCarthy saw
it that way now I also saw
that you both were talking to various
Democrats during the process and you
especially were talking to Congressman
congresswoman Jaya Paul and others was
there any thought of a deal with
Democrats during this process ever
absolutely not I was actually pretty
cozy talking to the news Well nothing
wrong with that I mean they're fun
people just like Republicans if you want
to know what I was talking with
congresswomanjay Paul about it was about
the big Tech legislation that I
supported with her to break up these
companies and we were talking about
during Republican control could we get
those bills to the floor that Nancy
Pelosi wouldn't bring to the floor while
her husband was trading big tech stocks
could you work with some people on the
left on some of these issues
congresswoman bobert because you know
you guys are vilified right you know
people were tough funny last week I was
kind of tough on you last week but there
are a lot of great things that were done
because of what you guys did to hold out
on this stuff so could you guys work
together I believe that the Congress is
going to be much stronger than it was
going into this the Republican party and
we will be able to work with some
Democrats there were many Democrats who
campaigned on conservative values and I
want to hold them to it they were
talking about securing a border and
reducing inflation and energy
Independence even and this was a battle
in a lot of Elections that we were
seeing so I want to hold them to that to
those promises and bring them into into
the Committees and have these
discussions to actually move things
forward that would be ironic back on
track yeah that would be ironic if
ironic if it were more bipartisan as a
result of all this right we'll see
Congressman Gates Congressman bober
thank you both for showing up tonight we
really appreciate it hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else